le directeur artistique de la brasserie
dunham au réussi à combiner sa passion
pour la bière et pour l'illustration en
misant sur des étiquettes original créé
par des artistes venus de tous horizons
il omet mis sur pied un journal qui
répertorie les plus belles étiquettes
il ya des gens qui m'écrivent de partout
dans le monde parce qu'ils ont trouvé
une copie du journal quelque part à
l'instar de la brasserie dunham
collective otsc brewing le brasseur
artisanal d'hamilton en ontario mise sur
des collaborations avec des artistes
pour se démarquer une tendance
planétaire
non ce mondial il ya définitivement les
brasseries qui qui se démarquent j'irai
avec cette approche l'homme qui aime
beaucoup à travailler avec des artistes
différents puits qui ont ce qu'ils sont
pas chères sur une image de marque
geneviève godbout illustre généralement
des livres pour enfants créé l'image de
la bière mathari était pour elle un beau
défi la zone de confort habituel en
termes de paix les attentes qu'on a de
ce que je dessinais habituellement les
trucs un peu plus mignon on parle d'une
bière on parle d'une espionne des
dessins qui donne aussi des indices sur
le goût de la bière
j'avais envie coopération entre la côte
et colorée et côté bière d'été aussi
donc j'avais envie que ce soit c'est
clair vous l'image du coup les magrets
as ne pas de doute même si l'objectif
est de vendre un produit
la démarche artistique reste la même oui
c'est là c'est le sait la commerciale et
d'une installation c'est la populaire
donc à le visuel est très bon pour le
propriétaire de cette épicerie
spécialisée
pas de doute nos goûts en matière de
bière racines on voit vraiment
l'augmentation de l'apport brassicole la
qualité où ça en même temps délicate
pour me guider l'enfant le client tant
que tel et ça fonctionne pour moi c'est
oui parce qu'il ya tellement de produits
qu'est-ce qui va se démarquer alors
l'éthique est un peu comme un album de
musique des fois des requêtes envie de
garder parce qu'elles sont vraiment très
mène des bouteilles qui sont en effet du
véritable oeuvre d'art via des
collectionneurs d'étiquettes de bière de
par le monde
c'est du sérieux collection il n'y a pas
une semaine qui passe ici cinq ans
reçoivent pas un courrier d'europe de
l'est ou de chevaux du monde qui nous
demandent des extraits pour leur
collection
les bières de microbrasseries sont un
plaisir pour le goût pour le doha pour
louis et grâce au travail d'illustrateur
pour la vue santé ici n'est bien
lexandre chartier radio-canada d'honneur